right now in portland oregon
children are being forced to eat lunch
outside i don't know if you're very
familiar with portland oregon but it's a
little chilly there someday can be it
can get a little cold
kindergarteners this story came out last
week kindergarteners are forced to eat
lunch outside separated on these little
buckets so that they can social distance
in 40 degree weather maybe a little bit
colder
at the capitol hill elementary school
there
and that way they won't be near their
friends they can't huddle for warmth and
they're going to sit outside so they're
not going to catch the wu flu they might
catch pneumonia which is going to be a
lot more dangerous for the kids but at
least they'll be able to avoid the
omicron which has not
seriously affected anybody in the united
states does that make sense to you no it
doesn't make much sense to me either
seems
ignorant seems like child abuse
but it seems like it's not letting up
anytime soon
when guests come up to my door this
holiday season this is how i'm gonna
greet them i'm gonna greet them holding
up these two gigantic knives to show off
the incredible japanese steel that they
are made with kamikoto makes great
japanese steel kitchen knives using more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from japan each knife comes in a
beautiful wooden heavy duty box it makes
sure that the knives are stored safely
and it makes kamikodo a great gift each
kamikoto knife goes through a rigorous
19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish to complete the
expert bladesmiths forage and shape raw
steel into hardy blades polishing and
sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected kamikoto
is so confident about their knives that
each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee i really strongly recommend it
kamikoto is currently having a massive
christmas sale and on top of that sale
you can get an additional fifty dollars
off any purchase you make
with discount code knowles canon wles so
click the link below
or go to
slash
kamikodo.com
and use promo code knowles canon wles to
save an extra 50 bucks today
did you like that clip be honest listen
you're not gonna hurt my feelings and i
and i think i hope you like that clip if
you want to get more videos you got to
ring the bell
and subscribe and if you want to get all
the real notifications and not have our
friends in big tech shut you up you got
to go to apple podcasts spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five-star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you